some of them might save middle-earth and
some of them might destroy it from
fateful decisions to political intrigue
to the greedy pursuit of treasure the
characters of the rings of power have
lived dramatic lives here's what you
need to know about all of them galadriel
is no stranger to fans of the lord of
the rings the lady of lorian is one of
the most memorable and important
characters tolkien ever created and kate
blanchett's portrayal of her in the
movie adaptations is nothing less than
iconic the version of galadriel we meet
in the rings of power however may not be
the one you're expecting this story
begins in a time of relative peace after
the defeat of the dark lord morgoth and
the world shattering war of wrath that
closed out the first age gladreal is
considerably more brazen at this point
as she hunts down the remnants of
morgoth's forces to avenge her brother's
death after she completes her mission
and abandons her journey back into the
west galadriel encounters hallbrand a
mortal man whose fate is apparently
intertwined with that of the future elf
queen before that fateful encounter
though she spends time with elrond in
the elven realm of linden and eventually
even sets foot on the island realm of
numenor considering the breath of these
travels it's clear that this more
reckless galadriel is one of the main
characters of the rings of power if not
the outright protagonist
during the third age elrond is one of
the most highly respected and
experienced elf lord still in middle
earth you're probably well aware of his
role in tolkien's more famous works in
the hobbit he briefly allows thorin
oakenshield's company to stay in
rivendell in the lord of the rings he
heals frodo after the attack on
weathertop hosts the council of elrond
and then takes one of the last ships
into the west the rings of power
features a very different elrond at this
point still young and determined elrond
plays a part in the politics heavy
linden storyline
it is said the wine of victory is
sweetest
for those in whose bitter trials it has
fermented he also pays a visit to the
dwarves of khazad doom suggesting the
young elf lord's politicking may extend
beyond his homeland's borders you can
expect far greater things from elrond as
the series goes on throughout the second
age he proves himself as a military
commander during the elves conflict with
sauron establishes rivendell takes
possession of velia the ring of air and
helps overthrow the dark lord in the war
of the last alliance there can be little
doubt that these events will be depicted
in the rings of power and that by the
end of the series this young elf will
have grown into the great leader he is
destined to become
one of the most exciting aspects of the
rings of power is that it will bring
characters who have previously been
little more than legends to the screen
gilgalad is the high king of the noldor
and ruler of linden the elven realm that
lies in the western regions of
middle-earth a wise leader and fierce
warrior gilgalad appears in a poem
recited by samweis gamji which tells of
his keen lands shining helm silver
shield who eventually falls into
darkness indeed you could reasonably
argue that gilgalad as a key military
commander and sworn enemy of sauron is
the most important elf to live in middle
earth during the second age in the rings
of power gilglad appears to be exactly
as magnificent as his reputation
suggests when galadriel returns from her
last mission to the north he presides
over a ceremony granting her and her
soldiers passage into the west he wears
golden robes during the ceremony and
places a crown of golden laurels on
galadriel's head later in the season the
elf king hosts a magnificent feast for a
few dwarven visitors including during
the fourth these are mere hints towards
gilgalad's greater importance of course
but it seems certain we'll see much much
more of him in the coming years
a skilled smith who witnesses the many
calamities of the first age kelebrimbor
is best known for forging the rings of
power he first makes several lesser
rings crafted under the tutelage of
sauron disguised as the elf anatar the
lord of gifts then by himself he creates
the more powerful three rings after
sauron reveals himself and forges the
one ring things go south pretty quickly
for keller brimbore in the second
episode of the first season kelebrimbor
personally asks for elrond's assistance
in building a tower that will house the
most powerful forge ever created by
elves humans or dwarves it's a
foreboding look at the master
craftsman's dark fate though we likely
won't see his fall from grace until much
later in the series some fans have
complained about charles edwards look as
keller brimbler but however cranky they
currently feel fans might rest a little
easier knowing he is a renowned actor of
both stage and screen he starred in
shows such as the crown and downton
abbey as well as productions of richard
ii and much ado about nothing in short
calibribor is in very good hands
in 2019 deadline reported that game of
thrones star joseph malley had been cast
as the show's villain ored since sauron
is the principal threat to middle earth
during the second age this led many to
assume oren was a production code name
and that mali was in fact playing the
dark lord himself they were half right
as it turns out thanks to a leaked
character sheet oren is indeed a
pseudonym for a character named adar the
sheet describes the character as an elf
tortured corrupted turned into a warlord
subsequent leaks and rumors suggest adar
will lead an orc band hunting an
enigmatic artifact and that he will face
off against sauron most intriguingly
adar may be revealed to be one of
galadriel's brothers perhaps the same
brother she's avenging as the series
begins this would be an astonishing
break from tolkien's canon imagining
galadriel's brother as a corrupted
warlord borders on the sacrilegious at
the very least it'll be fascinating to
see how mckay and payne might attempt to
pull off a twist like this
prince duran iv is said to be one of the
most important dwarven characters in the
rings of power but who is he during the
fourth is a second age ruler of causa
doom and a bearer of one of the rings of
power his name is important every once
in a while a prince or king of the house
of durian is born who is almost
identical in appearance and manner to
during the deathless eldest of the
dwarves who first awoke many millennia
ago these dwarves are named durin and
are believed by their kin to be a
genuine reincarnation of the original in
total six dwarves have been given the
name during throughout middle earth's
history while it's currently unclear
what specific part prince during will
have to play in the series it will have
something to do with keller brimmwar's
forge and you can safely bet he'll be
playing it from within the kingdom of
kaza doom later known as morya tolkien
writes in the lord of the rings that
even as sauron's forces spread across
middle-earth khalsa doom remained
unconquered due to the strength and
bravery of its people prince durian will
likely lead them for much of the show's
run
the dwarven storyline in the rings of
power poses a curious question if during
the fourth is the prince of causa doom
who's the king the answer during the
third despite the fact that in tolkien's
writings during the third and during the
fourth live thousands of years apart
they'll be brought together as father
and son in the new series by its
condensed timeline this will avoid huge
time jumps and associated issues with
human characters mortality you've always
had sandstone in your granite as far as
the elves were concealed
in the original text during the third
has a much more explicit role in the
events surrounding sauron's rise than
during the fourth this is the king who
is first gifted a ring of power by
sauron and who later leads his dwarves
into battle against the dark lord before
retreating to kazadum and closing the
doors of durian for good
it should be expected that the
relationship between father and son will
be severely tested as the days grow
darker for the dwarves of kaza doom
rounding out the show's dwarven
protagonists is princess dessau
currently there's not a lot known about
desa in the second episode of the rings
of power she's introduced as jordan the
fourth's strong-willed and loving wife
and the mother to two very energetic
children a leak that occurred before the
show premiered suggests that season one
will include a dwarven religious sect
given that diesa can be seen singing at
a dwarven ceremony in one of the
trailers could deesa be a leader of this
group or some kind of priestess how
might she play into the politics of the
subterranean kingdom what impact will
she have on the fates of the two durians
only time will tell iran deer was
created for the rings of power he's one
of the sylvan elves who populate the
greenwood and lothlorien but render's
journey takes him far beyond these
forest realms iran deer falls into a
forbidden romance with bronwyn a human
woman while stationed at a watchtower in
the southern lens the storyline seems
inspired by other human elf romances in
tolkien's work aragorn and arwen in the
lord of the rings and baron and luthien
in the silmarillion are prominent
examples though it has yet to be
revealed what troubles might underlie
arandir and ronwin's relationship twice
in known history has a pairing between
elves and humans even been attempted and
on each occasion it ended in tragedy
somewhat less murky is the setting for
this drama bronwyn's village tirarod was
created for the series but the name
literally near harad suggests it's close
to harad a mysterious region located
south of mordor the view from mirandi's
watchtower reveals a lot about this land
the geography of the valley below bears
a striking resemblance to the river and
duin the hills of emin arnon and the
ethel duoth mountain range that makes up
mordor's western border this could mean
much of render's season 1 story takes
place in and around the forest later
known as ethilian the perfect home for a
lovesick wood elf
an inhabitant of tyrod bronwyn is a
healer and a single mother to son theo
by episode 2 there is still little else
known about the woman who loves iran
dear however she quickly proves her
resourcefulness and determination when
she saves theo from a goblin that has
burrowed up from beneath her house this
occurs shortly after she returns from
her hometown which has been destroyed
under mysterious circumstances using the
severed head of the goblin she convinces
her fellow villagers to abandon their
homes in the event that tirarod suffers
the same fate early in the series theo
discovers a broken sword hidden in the
floorboards of a barn the weapon is
currently a total mystery for a while
speculation ran rampant that it could be
gurthang the sword of turin tarambar
however wright's restrictions prevent
amazon from using material found solely
in the silmarillion now that we can
watch the full episodes and have gotten
a good look at the design of the sword's
hilt and pommel and sauron's mark on the
blade this proves that it's definitively
a weapon of the dark lord it's clear
that theo has some kind of connection to
the wider events of the second age and
that the tirarod storyline will reach
far beyond the secret romance at its
core another character created for the
rings of power hallbrand is a mortal man
running from his past by episode 2 we
still know little about the mysterious
figure though he clearly has some
compassion as hallbrand and galadriel
attempt to survive on a makeshift raft
the elf is dragged under the waves
during a powerful storm hallbrand dives
in and rescues her from a watery grave
this of course is after he abandoned
several other survivors from his ship
when it was attacked by a giant sea
monster in one of the character posters
for the show paul brandt is seen holding
a sword with a horsehead pommel while it
might be easy to assume that this has
something to do with the rohirum it's
worth remembering that the horselords of
rohan don't exist at this point in
middle earth's history paul brand's
sword likely indicates he is numenorean
tolkien writes in unfinished tales that
the dunadine loved horses and riding and
became so attuned to their steeds that
they could call them to their side by
merely thinking it so there have also
been images of him wearing a tunic
marked with a solar symbol similar to
one found on another character poster
fans have speculated this icon may
belong to the numenorean noble elendil
that's as far as our knowledge of
hallbrand goes currently it'll probably
be a while before we find out who he
really is what he's running from and
what he might become
the stranger is by far the most
mysterious character in the rings of
power he arrives in middle earth via
fireball which can be seen streaking
across the sky the relationship between
the stranger and the harfoot nori who
first encounters him seems to be a
central storyline for the series the
stranger could be a wizard but he
probably isn't even if he is he almost
certainly won't be the one you're
thinking of gandalf radagast and saruman
all come to middle earth in the third
age long after the events of the show
take place the stranger might be one of
the two blue wizards but it seems odd to
introduce one with such fanfare and not
the other all things considered it's not
particularly plausible that the stranger
is one of these starry
so who is he well you might want to
consider a character you won't find
elsewhere on this list someone who is
guaranteed to play a major role in the
series one of the most famous aspects of
sauron's story during the second age is
that he comes to the elves disguised in
a form so fair that few suspect his true
identity what better way of delivering a
truly shocking twist than to make the
audience believe they're watching a
kindly wizard befriend a humble harfoot
when they are in fact witnessing the
return of the new dark lord
nobody expected to see hobbits in the
rings of power mostly because they don't
show up in middle earth's history until
the third age and yet here they are or
at least their ancestors the harfoots
like the hobbits are short and have
hairy feet but that's where the
resemblance ends the harfoots are a
nomadic group still searching to find
their place in the world the shows
featured harfoots nori brandyfoot poppy
proudfellow largo brandyfoot and
marigoldbrandyfoot encounter the
stranger on their travels which changes
their lives forever the series depiction
of this tribe of halflings is almost
entirely lifted from concerning hobbits
the first chapter of the lord of the
rings this prologue explains that in the
so-called wandering days hobbits
inhabited the upper veils of anduin to
the east of the misty mountains
according to tolkien the harfots had
much to do with dwarves in ancient times
and long lived in the foothills of the
mountains only when the fortress of dol
guldur rose in the early third age did
the hobbits migrate westwards eventually
settling in the lands that became the
shire clearly these aren't the simple
merry gardeners we all know and love but
the harford's tale should nevertheless
offer up a tantalizing opportunity to
explore the secret history of one of
middle earth's most remarkable races
i can't help but feel there's
wonders in this world
beyond our wondering
because of the show's condensed timeline
we can assume the movers and shakers of
late numenorean history will be present
from early on including isildur son of
ellendyl and future king of gondor at
this point in time isildor is heir to
the lordship of endunia a seaport
located on the island's west coast
notably he is not yet king and at the
beginning of the story does not expect
to become one as the days grow darker
and sauron's shadow falls upon numenor
however a steel door will doubtlessly be
drawn into the dark lord's deadly
schemes if you're familiar with the lord
of the rings you know this ends
tragically one report claims he'll
accompany galadriel elendil and the
numenorean queen muriel on a maritime
journey to middle-earth where exactly
are they going and why
your guess is as good as ours
better known to lord of the rings fans
as high king of the dunadine and founder
of both gondor and arnor allendel's rise
to glory and eventual death at the hands
of sauron is sure to be a key storyline
in the rings of power early on though
he's merely a numenorian lord albeit a
powerful one it's rumored that allendale
will head up recruitment efforts and
lead the numenorean fleet on its voyage
to middle-earth tolkien writes in the
appendices to the lord of the rings that
the numenoreans began to settle in
middle-earth around the year sa-1200 a
few hundred years before the forging of
the rings of power
since the series condenses the timeline
to a single generation it makes sense
that season one will see the island
nation spread its influence across
middle earth allendel it appears will
lead that effort as the seasons go by
expect to see him come increasingly into
conflict with far zone king of numenor
as the latter falls under the influence
of the dark lord the past is dead
we either move forward
or we die with it
an epic saga is only as great as its
monsters while sauron will undoubtedly
be doing much of the heavy lifting in
this department in the rings of power
numenorean king farzone is nothing to be
trifled with far zone the golden becomes
king of numenor after forcibly marrying
muriel daughter of tarpon tear the
previous king after sauron conquers much
of middle earth and declares himself
king of men uninfuriated farzone invades
the mainland swiftly and decisively
defeating the dark lord when the
numenoreans take sauron back to their
homeland as a hostage however he quickly
gets to work corrupting them for his own
ends far zone's subsequent fall into
darkness has world changing consequences
it appears that at the beginning of
season 1 farzone is merely a subject of
tar polynei and an advisor to his future
wife muriel the show's far zone is a
brilliant authoritative and
self-important type which suggests the
character's wicked personality is
already fully formed even if his tragic
fate has yet to play out
muriel is the daughter of tarpalantir
the king of numenor and the unwilling
wife to be of far zone tolkien wrote
little about tarmurial aside from the
disturbing nature of her marriage but it
appears that she'll be a significant
part of the numenorean storyline in the
rings of power it appears that muriel
will experience visions of numenor's
eventual destruction it's also reported
that muriel will be a queen during the
events of the show though her father is
still alive it's not yet known why this
might be it's said that she'll be a
savvy intelligent and compassionate
ruler and will see action in at least
one battle after joining the numenorean
expedition to middle-earth it's clear
that the show's version of muriel will
have much more impact on the history of
middle-earth than her literary
counterpart
tarpalantir is unusual among the late
kings of numenor though his immediate
predecessors mistrusted the elves and
the godlike valor he takes a royal name
in the elvish language quenya as well as
the
title tar as opposed to r taken from the
numenorean language this puts him at
odds with his own people who are
provoked by far zone into open rebellion
after tar polynei dies far zone usurps
the throne and marries his daughter
muriel tarpalantir is definitely in the
show though he likely won't be a major
player we currently have no idea who'll
be playing him most probably tarpon tier
will be an elderly ruler with diminished
authority as the series opens his main
purpose will be to open up a power
vacuum allowing the villainous far zone
to ascend to the throne of numenor
the rings of power will feature several
ancillary numenorean characters all of
whom are original to the series the
first is aryan isildur's sister who is
played by emma horvath aryan is set
against isildur's decision to join the
numenorean expedition to middle-earth at
one point she chases him through the
city streets as he leads his soldiers to
war finally there's kevin as far zone's
son kevin will spend season 1 involved
in a romance with aryan kevin is played
by leon waddem but it's unclear what his
role in the larger story of the rings of
power will be as galadriel narrates the
early days of arda she speaks briefly
about the years of trees and the great
wars that dominated the first age
shortly after we meet her brother finrod
feligant as her narration continues it's
revealed that he is one of the great
elven warriors determined to end
morgoth's reign of terror in middle
earth much of the introduction to the
rings of power is condensed likely
because a majority of the story takes
place during the second age but the
particular battle that galadriel
references might be the culmination of
and ultimate end to the first stage
there's a lot to digest here in
tolkien's writing finrod is an elven
king and brother of galadriel he plays a
key role in the events of the first age
and eventually gives his life to save
baron from torture at the hands of
sauron who at that point is merely a
lieutenant of the dark lord morgoth the
battle in question could be the epic
decor bragalok or even a glimpse of
baron's quest for the silmaril
unfortunately most of this material is
found in the silmarillion which means
amazon studios can't use it for the
series luckily the appendices of the
lord of the rings do mention a few key
details about finrod including his
familial relationship with galadriel and
the manner of his death the odds are
that finrod's appearance in the rings of
power will be relegated to the show's
prologue which with some clever trickery
and editing could feasibly depict middle
earth's ancient history without
committing copyright infringement
in may 2022 amazon invited a number of
token fan blogs websites and youtubers
to a special event in london where they
were introduced to the showrunners and
shown footage from the rings of power
information about the event has since
started popping up all over the internet
according to several sources show
creators patrick mckay and john d payne
told the attendees they have plans for
all the characters in the second age
specifically naming kell born and
calibrian as examples these names will
be familiar to fans of the lord of the
rings kelliborn is galadriel's husband
while calabrian is elrond's ill-fated
wife neither kellebor nor calibrian will
be appearing in season one for a long
time their absence from the cast list
was pretty conspicuous now though we
know that these two characters will
simply be making their debut at a later
point this makes total sense considering
how many characters are due to appear in
the series it stands to reason that a
few may need to be kept off the board
for a while and if nothing else it's
greatly reassuring to know that the
storytellers behind the rings of power
know exactly where their tail is headed
[Music]